reading the work of guy standing and
carl weiderquist and and all the way
back to uh thomas paine to understand
the real roots of of ubi which is is not
basic income it's a social dividend it's
it's everyone getting a share of
something that they that they should be
owning
and and that got me really excited
because i can see how
uh what i'm starting to call
commonwealth dividends can work with a
guaranteed minimum income together where
as martin luther king
who is four guaranteed minimum income he
encouraged his followers that we need to
do more than just give money to people
who need it we should question the
economic system that creates need in the
first place
and to me
i've started to think about this concept
of
of of creating common wealth literally
wealth we own in common like like like
sovereign wealth funds like they have in
norway in alaska where people feel they
own the oil and they're sharing the
dividends so so i'm starting to think
that there's maybe actually two
movements here that that need to happen
separately and not be confused with each
other one is the anti-poverty movement
that's for an income guarantee and the
other one is a movement that i'm calling
uh commonwealth dividends to create
common wealth that can actually is how
we could get to star trek the next
generation as an economic system
[Music]
welcome to yang speaks
the andre yang of canada my good friend
humanist visionary co-founder of ubi
works floyd marinescu how are you floyd
i'm great it's so great to be here with
you it's such a pleasure and uh i really
yeah it's it's awesome you've done so
much work and you've been a big
inspiration for me andrew well thank you
floyd you inspired me too you and i met
back when i was running for president
uh and you were one of the folks that
got behind the campaign early on you ran
a conference
and you actually had me address the
conference of techies in san francisco
which was a delight and i'm sure
generated some support you personally
donated to the the uh campaign in the
ways that you could you uh crowd support
and meanwhile you are actually
taking matters into your own hands north
of the border where you said you know
what they should have universal
uh basic income we should have universal
basic income in canada
and so yeah um so you and i have been
friends for years uh first how the heck
did you find out about universal basic
income because it predated
me yeah i remember um
elon musk i think first said the word
and like what's that and uh i was busy
running my software developer education
company for the last 15 years and when i
heard about i'm like oh my god i mean we
can have
we can have a capitalism and have no
poverty we can have a system that works
for everyone it's so simple and i
thought about the impact would have had
on my family growing up where money was
a huge source of tension often even
violence and like it would have been a
huge huge difference so i'm like one as
soon as i heard this idea and i started
looking into it i just it captivated my
imagination i spent a couple years just
learning about it like a hobby
and uh yeah and then when you were um
i think i was doing my running my
software developer conference qcon in
new york in june 18 2018 and i heard you
were speaking and like i have to go see
this guy
and i kind of you know
wiggled my way into your campaign
headquarters and got to know you guys
better and that was awesome
yeah so that was 2018. you and i have
been friends for a few years when did
you first hear elon musk talk about it
oh i must have been 2016 i think yeah or
maybe it wasn't him i think it was him
but i just kept reading about it and uh
and trying to bring like yeah
understanding like what are the
economics around it and trying to figure
out like what well why don't we already
have it and uh i yeah so in canada
it was amazing because we were
we had the most world leading most
important basic income trial
ever in like
dozens of years happening in ontario
which is my home province or state for
those in america and uh and it suddenly
got canceled in uh i believe it was 2019
in the summer
and i was so mad
that uh no i was 2018 also sorry 2018
july i just started a sabbatical from
work first time my whole life i was
going to not work for a few months i was
like
looking forward to relax and suddenly i
cancelled and i was so mad that i just
like i got to do something so i
corralled um 100 ceos me and a friend
like went through a rolodex of every
business owner we knew to sign a letter
to ask the premier of the province to
not cancel the pilot so that was kind of
the beginning of my activation as an
activist
and uh yeah so that was kind of where it
started
so you referenced growing up in canada
and struggling with money or your family
struggles with money can you talk a
little bit about your background
yeah well kind of typical immigrants of
you know came here with nothing from a
former communist country
father is pretty uh right wing like saw
like how bad you know
totalitarianism can get came here tried
to make life for himself and um you know
but growing up you know we all had a lot
of the tensions from back home like
money was scarce um
and uh often was the cause of a lot of
tension and
anger growing up around that it was just
really really difficult for everyone and
uh uh in in my life also i mean if i had
if if we hadn't had a basic income at
the time it would have been very
different i think things have been much
better uh between my parents would have
been much better for everyone and um
even i might have made a different
career choice maybe i would not have
gone into computer science we would have
gone to something else like uh money
really motivates decisions and at the
end of the day it comes down to
long-term income security and and the
world that we can have everyone has
long-term income security the better
plans they can make the more freedom
they can have to to do what's best for
them
so you grew up in canada then you went
to school in canada and studied computer
science is that right how did you go
about starting your business
yeah i went to university of waterloo
for computer science um honestly again
mainly because of money like my pri
probably first career choice would have
been psychology third might have been a
massage therapist
but
i uh i went to computer science because
at waterloo because they had a co-op
program and i knew i could i could uh
make money quicker and uh not have to
rely on my parents and uh which i ended
up getting a co-op internship in uh
silicon valley in 97 and was out and
about networking trying to make the most
of being there and uh just met a guy who
hired me to build a news website for
software engineers uh and uh as a
student and i did and i was like running
that like a business within his business
and uh that turned out to be quite a
success um for the java programmer
community i was sort of a mini celebrity
i was like 22 years old keynoting around
the world talking about trends in java
no one thought i was that young because
i was writing all the news on this
website this is before blogs existed
kind of like the first blog
for tech and uh yeah and then um a few
years later i didn't like the new owners
and it was just all about dollars and
cents they weren't about the community
didn't even really understand the
audience so i quit and started the
competition to my original site and
that's infoq.com now and uh we went
international from day one we had we had
uh translations in china we had in
portuguese and multiple languages then
we started doing events in new york san
francisco london like uh beijing
shanghai sao paulo so it's all over the
world doing these tech conferences
for software engineers and running this
news website so i have a media
background and uh that was uh how i got
started
uh it sounds like
in 2018 you gathered together these
hundred business leaders
and they said please continue this
basic income trial
um
and uh that kicked off your political
activism
in canada is that right and what has
developed since then because i know
you've been very busy
yeah you know it's really interesting
because um people keep telling me that
i'm doing politics but i think of myself
as not doing politics as uh as building
a movement as uh i i kind of think in
terms of marketing terms
i never really thought of
politics my whole life much i liked i
was kind of an amateur economist that
was interesting to me but uh
so i like to think of what we do so
after that i i self-funded
ubi works for the first couple years
which is a non-profit that promotes
basic income in canada we recently
started asking for donations i wanted to
make sure like any entrepreneur that we
can do a good job before asking for
money like you know you don't go to the
investors that is not what most
entrepreneurs do uh that's what good
entrepreneurs like you do
i want to make sure we have good
products a good team you know investors
invest in good in winning teams not not
just ideas
so so you can donate to ebi works right
now whoever's listening um and uh so i
think of ubi works as like a marketing
agency uh for an idea and and i focus on
canada because there's a lot of people
in the u.s like yourself uh canada
doesn't really have anyone that's
thinking about it from a technology
entrepreneurial background with with
marketing skills to make this happen so
now two years later been focused on that
with most of my time
and resources and uh we have almost four
full-time people uh we've become the
largest
movement builder in the country we have
our email list is almost 60 000 names at
this time 30 000 facebook followers
uh we do all kinds of things that a that
a marketing agency would do you know so
the four ps of marketing product
placement promotion so for example we
want basic income discussed as an
economic recovery measure so we worked
with the canadian center of economics
analysis to produce a report that showed
that basic income would create six
hundred thousand jobs and add eighty
billion dollars to gdp which is as much
as canada's pre tour um pre-covered
tourism and hospitality industries
combined this is an independent report
and then we use our network to promote
the heck out of this thing like every mp
in the country knew about it like at the
local level um we were hammering this
idea everywhere because as you know
politicians are accountable for economic
growth we must link basic income to
being good for the economy
and one thing is that we did so overall
we see
everything
from the lens of how do we de-risk basic
income for a political party to run on
that's our core strategy we think basic
income does require an election mandate
because it isn't cheap and uh so we need
to de-risk support so we're building a a
voter base from the bottom up that's
active and engaged there's like
thousands of likes every day in our
facebook we're petitions all the time
and soon we're going to be organizing
marches uh starting in september where
there might be an election in the
country to really put it on the map and
i want to do marches twice a year or
every march the goal is to be double the
size of the previous one and we'll keep
doing it and doing it until the pressure
is overwhelming and the government's uh
the parties will choose to run on it
because they'll believe that they can
win so that that is our overall mission
is uh make basic income an election
issue
so if you have friends in canada and
you're listening to this and they don't
know about ubi works then out of this
mailing list let them know point them to
floyd uh because i don't know about the
rest of you but this sounds magical
[Music]
uh one of the rules of thumb i have is
that canada is approximately 10 the size
of the united states of america
so
it's very
possible in my mind to have a a rapid
impact there
more
easily than might be the case in the
united states of america
it's just my feeling like i feel like
you floyd can get to anyone in your
country pretty quickly i don't know if
that that's uh an accurate feeling
i was surprised that mps actually do um
do do pick up calls if they feel they'll
learn something new or you have to
especially if you have a big following
they'll pick up a call and i'm sure
you've noticed that so uh like you we
also spent some money on lobbying so we
could actually reach people people in
government to tell them about this
economics report because we need this
idea to spread so people do respond but
you know i'm sure you've encountered
this too like at least uh members of
parliament or congress people they're
really more influencers than anything
else like at the end of the day it's the
parties that have to run on something
i guess in america to be different like
because people can
propose independent things so we're
doing whatever we can like another thing
we're doing again from an election
readiness perspective is is to show that
we can pay for a basic income without
costing uh middle class voters so so we
can pay for it without costing people
who make under 100k or even 150k and
we're sh and without avoiding the the
extreme left versus right uh ideas that
tend to um uh put people in boxes so
we're working on this right now so we
have to have this stuff ready
um
in canada though it's interesting it's
i like to talk a bit about a couple
couple years of learning i've had in
basic income and how i've been able to
untangle
ubi from guaranteed minimum incomes in
my mind um because it took me a while to
figure that out you know having come
from a technology background been in
love with your campaign and uh yeah it
was quite painful actually to uh to come
to go through this learning journey
well hopefully you picked up some things
from my campaign
that enabled you to speed up or avoid a
pitfall or something along those lines
so i'm focused on trying to make these
things happen in the u.s
and you talked about how people in the
democratic or republican party can
propose something
um in
without their entire party being into it
which is accurate but then that thing
will not pass
so so i've been
uh
trying to chip away in various ways and
here in the united states
uh here are the encouraging things
at this point i feel like the argument
has been won because
literally
hundreds of millions of americans have
received a cash relief check
uh
probably at least three of them
um twelve hundred dollars six hundred
dollars and fourteen hundred dollars so
the two main arguments that i always had
to deal with which were number one where
do we get the money and now you're like
well turns out we kind of have the money
uh and two
people aren't going to spend the money
in positive ways and it's like well like
you got the money and what did you spend
it on
so i feel like most americans now are
like pretty down and a majority of
americans uh are pro um universal basic
income and cash relief right now the
thing that i'm looking at most intently
is this
child
tax credit that got implemented in july
and 36 million families which probably
means you know maybe twice that or three
times that in terms of number of lives
impacted so maybe 100 million lives
impacted directly and then all of us get
impacted indirectly
but 36 million families got
a child tax credit of let's call it 300
per child per month which would add up
to a lot like if you have two kids and
you got 600 bucks you would notice you
know i mean you get 600 bucks uh every
month for six months you'll be like wow
um but unfortunately the child tax
credit right now is scheduled to end at
the end of this year
which is going to be
an enormous deal
for all of those families and for the
country writ large and
it's a no-brainer in my mind to extend
the child tax credit um
in perpetuity ideally
um so those are some of the things that
we're focused on here and when i say we
you know like i have my role to play um
humanity forward has
a lobbying presence on dc where they're
talking about some of the things you're
talking about which are the
policy impacts of cash relief to people
on different points in the political and
ideological spectrum so republicans
talking about how it's great for the
economy and entrepreneurship and
business starts
and then for democrats about all of the
help it gives people and families
um so
that's
front one in the the fight is just
talking to legislators um so right now
what does that look like on your end uh
in canada
is there a lobbying effort and it would
be it's very advanced to have a lobbying
effort so it wouldn't surprise me if
you're just now starting to examine that
um so canada already has a uh a child
benefits we've had it for for several
years
and um uh and it's permanent and uh it's
a graduated system so the less you have
the more you make but it tapers off all
the way up to families of 150 000 in
income
and uh interestingly it used to be more
like ubi um when it was previously
created by a conservative government it
was only a few hundred bucks a month uh
per family even for those who didn't
need it and then the liberal government
got elected uh ways back they converted
into a
a um
a graduated what format where if if
you're in poverty and you have kids you
can get up to six hundred dollars per
child per month and that tapers down and
interestingly that it did grow the
economy it did make a big impact in fact
i remember re hearing the governor of
the bank of canada showing off in a
podcast in um a couple years afterwards
it was implemented that the reason why
canada led the g7 in economic growth i
think it was in 2017 he said is because
of the canada child benefit like
literally said is because of that and uh
and also recently uh canada is one of
the few countries where the genie
coefficient the measures of inequality
have been actually improving and people
have studied it say that the
overwhelming reason there's many reasons
but the main reason is the canada child
benefit so it really works for both
both helping people and growing the
economy
and um so one of the first things we did
actually was to
fund uh uh some research into it that
showed an independent researcher the
canadian center of economics analysis
show that every dollar invested in the
in the ccb creates two dollars of gdp
or rather contributes two dollars of gdp
some economists speak which is really
exciting so it works it's good for
everyone so you all already have that
which i think a lot of americans knew
but now hearing it you're like well even
i was like i knew that but i'm like wow
like canada's ahead of
the us in in many respects so because
you already have that then you can jump
to more robust forms of basic income
yeah let's talk about that so i have
this theory because i've been doing this
for two years talking to mps
we did some lobbying but again because
it's a party system i'm starting to
think that there's limited success
uh again
because basic income requires an
election mandate that's my presumption i
don't think any government could do it
without an election mandate because it
is a dramatic change in in in in in tax
policy it's it's not something you just
do even in a crisis apparently because
look we just had one they did something
like basic income but it was temporary
and uh we can get into that um but it
needs an election so at the end of the
day it's really the parties they have to
believe they can win and canada like the
us there's majority support there's
two-thirds support for basic income but
only one-third support of people who
said they'd pay for it so i think that's
true everywhere
that that's why um we've been focusing
on narratives and talking points to link
basic income to middle-class prosperity
because it's middle-class voters whose
minds you have to change
and in fact we've been working on
funding plans to show that they won't
even have to pay for it we can pay for
basic income through taxes on the
financial sector
taxes on passive wealth accumulation
that that won't even hurt economic
investment so that's been a focus of
ours very recently so we can show that
we can have this while actually making
the economy better definitionalizing it
a little bit putting more money in the
real economy which again would add 80
billion dollars to gdp but but back to
your original question
yes canada is further ahead there are a
lot of members of parliament that are
for it and they're all for a guaranteed
minimum income they want the most
incremental change to to reduce poverty
there and i felt like an alien sometimes
talked to them about a ubi which is a
much more expensive program on the
headline when they just want to do the
smallest thing possible to reduce
poverty by 50 or more and it would cost
four times less
and like the only thing i could tell
them about ubi is that well if you do
this it'll push the net payers above the
middle class into higher deciles and and
i just i kind of felt weird and after a
while i i started to kind of shift my
views on
the whole you know income testing versus
uh ubi
and um
it took me to a different place i you
know the the experts in the industry say
it's not means testing it's income
testing it's a simple income test on a
tax return
it's not like means testing like welfare
and it's cheaper so
you know you could have
a 50 reduction in poverty if canada
implements a guaranteed minimum income
like what was tried in ontario during
the canceled pilot of 17 000 a year so
higher min a higher benefit amounts and
it would cost eight times less than if
you gave everyone a thousand dollars a
month in terms of the gross costs
so um
heresy
i say floyd no i'm kidding um people ask
me all the time
um hey what about a negative income tax
uh that and and then i which is an idea
where essentially if you make below a
certain amount they true you up to that
amount and i hear that and i say i would
love a negative negative income tax like
that would be great
you know so i'm not dogmatic about the
version i think a guaranteed minimum
income is great i think which is
essentially identical to a negative
income tax
you said it at a particular level uh i
think that arguing for universal basic
income
um is more compelling and direct
and
avoid some of the administrative stuff
which is why i made the argument
and in america the way the numbers work
out like the people who are doing great
unfortunately are vastly outnumbered by
the people who are not doing that great
so it's like well if you gave somebody
more money you know c'est la vie um
but
but i i so it sounds like uh
policymakers are more wedded to poverty
reduction plans um and so uh you've
shifted in that direction in canada is
that right
the ogs and the movement as i like to
call them the original gangsters who
have been doing this for like decades
they're all retired former civil service
workers people retired senators people
who were in government and they
understand the realities of government
politics and
so they they want to reduce poverty
replace the
improve the social welfare system with
something that's not means tested and
has more dignity so they just want to
not ruffle things too much and while
i'll have the greatest impact on people
so i started to to feel a bit um
uh awkward talking about technology and
give everyone a share and this and that
and and it led me to a
um
yeah and actually along the way it's
interesting to mention i guess for the
american audience too like uh there is
also a version of ubi that i'm sure it
would work in the us too that a friend
of mine is a tax lawyer
and a number of cfos from high level uh
companies i know are in favor of is give
everyone two thousand dollars a month
and obliterate the tax code and
obliterate the all other income support
programs like make it really simple like
a fifty percent flat tax on for every
dollar over two thousand dollars a month
and that's it you have no the tax code
becomes like one page and and you're
done and like that sounds really cool
and smart but but when do smart things
get actually work in politics it's a
it's such a huge
huge cost
or change that it's hard to imagine
someone running on that and winning
[Music]
one of the frustrations people have in
the u.s uh is
the the
uh
maze of regulations like that i think
the number is that americans spend nine
billion hours uh figuring out our taxes
collectively like it's insane uh and
annie lowry called it the time tax
uh i called it the dignity tax
where there are all of these things
in
uh the labyrinthine code um and
everyone's attracted to simplifying it
the problem is that there are just
powerful interest groups that have built
up around every complication and you're
looking at absolutely changes that would
reduce their revenue uh in many cases by
hundreds of millions and the most
straightforward example of this is
something that i i find infuriating uh
but into it the makers of turbo tax have
assiduously lobbied to make sure that
you can't automatically have your taxes
filed because they make hundreds of
millions from the complexity
so there are going to be defenders of
complexity
it's awful in america it's uh
rampant
uh they and someone called it the
clutchocracy where it's like like people
are profiting from
uh the clogged pipes
and it's one of the legitimate
frustrations that drive a lot of
americans up a wall
where
uh if you heard trump's drain the swamp
stuff like a lot of people are
sympathetic to it because they feel like
there are these soulless bureaucracies
uh that
govern uh how much money you get or
whether you're truly disabled uh and
when you talk to canadian government
officials about the desire to reduce
poverty that's a frustration a lot of
people here have is that if you were to
go to legislators or policy makers and
say hey let's reduce poverty
then
there are a lot of people in power
that
don't really want to reduce poverty
or
or they want to make it very very
difficult
for someone to get
resources
uh and there have been a number of uh
republican politicians who've
essentially gone on the record saying
like we have to make the process
difficult and painful enough so that a
lot of people just get fed up and give
up and and don't get through like you
have to make it this massive
uh challenge to get resources
um
it's really
the worst of all worlds in many respects
i i think and this should be something
that americans of every political stripe
can get behind which is
trying to clean up the bureaucracy
trying to clean up the rules trying to
make it so that if you're entitled to
certain benefits uh they don't make you
jump through endless hoops
yeah absolutely um actually the
government in canada announced that
they're going to do automatic tax filing
like they have in the u.s and i think i
think the government is actually
sympathetic i i think it's not the right
time for them for their political
calculations so if you have automatic
tax filing more people will start to get
the existing income supports they never
knew they had because everything's
incontested and uh so that's kind of a
first step in that direction but um yeah
i mean canada the the the governing
party right now that talks a lot of
their mps there's a huge caucus of like
at least like 30 of the rmps that are
for basic income it was the number one
voted issue at the party platform which
means nothing about the actual party
running on it it just shows that the
party uh people themselves want it and
um and oddly enough like the the other
parties there's no official stance even
like the far far further left leading
party ndp has no official stance on
basic income some of their mps are for
introduced motions in the house
um and how many mps are there in total
uh 335.
wow that's such a familiar sounding
number
[Laughter]
so so there are 30
uh mps who are for basic income and are
they all in one party are they spread
out
um you know there's probably a lot more
than that there's there's at least 30
that showed up uh
on a call that we organized to hear
about the economics analysis report that
will grow the economy and uh that was
pretty cool at first in my life i ever
was able to effect something like that
to happen i was very proud of that um uh
but the party itself though is is it one
of the top resolutions i think number
two or three at the recent convention so
it's it's the party wants it it's it's
the the government the the actual
leaders that i think haven't run an
election on it yet and it seems like
they may not because everything they're
saying now is they want to introduce
child care affordable child care so more
women go and peop and men and people go
back to work um i mean i think basic
income would be as important or even
more important than that frankly um but
but yeah in this country like there is a
lot of support among mps in all parties
including the conservative party which
is why i think the discussion has moved
more towards an income guarantee versus
the ubi much like now you know ilan omar
did that that um policy recently in the
u.s that that bill um seems to go in
that direction but but it's it's led me
to to have a bit of a moral crisis
because you know i'm like with you that
we need to find a way to make technology
benefit everyone so we have a sense of
ownership in our economy and it occurred
to me that
that a true ubi cannot be separated from
its funding source the funding source
itself has to have some moral basis for
why we we believe we deserve an equal
right to it
because otherwise i don't see how i see
it failing a moral test if if you're
basically saying tax working people to
pay for other people who who work less
so it that put me down a whole learning
journey and reading the work of guy
standing and carl weiderquist and and
all the way back to uh thomas payne to
understand the real roots of of ubi
which is is not basic income it's a
social dividend it's it's everyone
getting a share of something that they
that they should be owning
and and that got me really excited
because i can see how uh what i'm
starting to call commonwealth dividends
can work with a guaranteed minimum
income together where as martin luther
king
who is four guaranteed minimum income he
encouraged his followers that we need to
do more than just give money to people
who need it we should question the
economic system that creates need in the
first place
and to me
i've started to think about this concept
of
of of creating common wealth literally
wealth we own in common like like like
sovereign wealth funds like they have in
norway and alaska where people feel they
own the oil and they're sharing the
dividends so so i'm starting to think
that there's maybe actually two
movements here that that need to happen
separately and not be confused with each
other one is the anti-poverty movement
that's for an income guarantee and the
other one is a movement that i'm calling
commonwealth dividends to create common
wealth that can actually is how we could
get to star trek the next generation as
an economic system and i have a lot more
to say about that um on the basis of
some of the predictions of john maynard
keynes uh if you're interested
well uh so i'm attracted to anything
that
enables dividends for people based upon
some
massive common resource so the the
common resources i've seen suggested
most often are
land
uh energy
carbon data
and when i was running for president or
considering my run for president i
thought about each of them
and i wanted to start at the end where i
just
cut straight to a thousand bucks a month
for everyone um because if i said hey
you're gonna get some tiny percentage of
uh this carbon tax or something like
that and then someone's asking how much
is that and then you're like well it
depends
like
like part of it was that i just thought
that uh it would be
very difficult uh to make the case but
the other
problem i had was that when i ran the
numbers
most of the time the dividend in
question
uh was not that large based upon current
numbers and some of them could become
quite large
it's one reason why i ended up landing
on a value-added tax was because
i was confident as you are that
eventually ai and technology are going
to be doing much more of the work uh our
current income tax system certainly in
the us is going to miss that canada has
a vat right
it it has a value-added tax which has
been reduced it became a bit of a
political ping pong which is a is
unfortunate because it is a tax favored
by economists that actually can uh
is non-distortionary and can can help
the economy so it's currently at five
percent which combined with the various
provincial level of taxes uh puts
canada's overall consumption taxes at uh
less than half of the european averages
well still five percent's five percent
higher than the us and the five percent
value-added tax in the us would be
enormous like my entire suggestion was
ten percent and that would have been
enough to fund just about anything you
need uh because our economy is so
massive
yeah i actually agree with you that um i
think given that you're running for
office you have to keep it simple and in
a sense a vat tax is a shortcut to
achieve
some of the benefits that actually
taxing
uh what is called economic rents which
we can get into would achieve indirectly
so i think it's so it's a simple policy
would have had the biggest impact which
again in my mind is coming back to this
whole thing that that you be that
ubi is both
trying to be an anti-poverty program but
also the the origins of it is more of a
social justice thing about getting your
share of something we own together and
those two things are actually not
compatible uh into i mean they are
somewhat if you had a share of what you
should rightfully own maybe there'd be
no poverty uh but it's a whole different
narrative an entry point and i'm not
running for anything so i've been
thinking about building a movement
around
commonwealth and commonwealth dividends
which is where we can affect the the
bigger changes that society needs to
achieve ecological and sustainability
less inequality because mean income
guarantee will only go so far as opposed
to a fundamental fix that can actually
uh save the planet and give us a sense
of shared ownership and shared shared
outcomes
and um so what i think i'm i mean i'm
into it so my question is how do you
define the common wealth from which the
dividends would flow
uh because again i tried to figure out
what this could look like and i i came
up short
yeah do you mind if we take a a bit of a
roundabout way to get there
yes i think okay so we both talk about
star trek you talked about it i thought
it was so cool
um you had that slide in your talk about
star trek versus mad max
and yeah which one are we heading
towards right now i think we all know
unfortunately
i think it's more like star trek versus
star wars because
my read on technology is that it's it's
not going to be no one having jobs it's
going to be what we have more of now
more low income jobs and more poverty
level jobs because as a business owner
there's always going to be unlimited
number of people i could hire if you can
hire them for almost nothing but there's
a fundamental almost like an injustice
in that if people can't afford to live
so so it's um the future we're seeing
from technology what we're seeing is
actually low income work predominantly
uh polarization of outcomes and that's
the biggest threat to democracy is
losing the middle class having
polarization of wages and jobs which has
been happening for decades
and
so i think all this frankly was foreseen
by one of the world's greatest
economists named john maynard keynes
and he wrote an essay
in 1930 actually he spent three years
noodling on it tweaking every word it
was called economic possibilities for
our grandchildren
we are keynes's grandchildren
and this essay is
incredible it is it describes a
beautiful world
that is is fundamentally how we get to a
star trek world and i've really unpacked
this essay to figure out what what he
was saying and all the analysis of it
and i think it points to this idea of
creating common wealth
so let's describe this world if you'll
indulge me
he talked about a world where the
economic problem has been solved
he defines the economic problem as a
struggle for subsistence
not not not great wealth not like saudi
arabia level wealth but just like
literally no one is struggling just to
survive
as a and he was very careful to
distinguish this from from struggling
for status people might still want to
keep up with the joneses want to drive a
tesla
and there's obviously forms of status
that are far better than just money
status like like contribution scientific
discovery having the best arts the
making the best cocktail there'll always
be struggles of some sort that'll put us
to work
but it doesn't have to be struggling to
survive he said we would have solved
that problem by 2030
and or at least know how we're going to
get there there'll be a path in sight he
said that
most people won't
there'll be so much abundance that
people will want to work
15 hours a week just to keep themselves
feeling useful
so the implication in that is that
people won't have to work uh although
commentators have latched on to that
number and said that keynes predicted
the 15-hour work week he said that
people would want to work and in fact
that if they're not working on things to
survive they'd be working on things to
help others
so for instance uh it doesn't mean that
in a world with a a generous ebi
there'll be no more people working at
starbucks like you might love being a
barista because you love people and
because it pays you better at post ebi
you negotiated a better salary you might
love being a bartender because you love
people and and you get more money for
every hour after 11 p.m because that's
kind of hazardous to be up so late all
the time um you might want to work for
elon musk because you believe in his
mission to get us to mars like that's
the world that he was describing is
people working out of a sense of of
purpose not out of need
so you know
he talked a lot about this concept of
enjoying life now not living and
sacrificing for a better future so not
like working your ass off now to retire
later no you effectively we've we've
built all this abundance we're retired
now but we want to work because we have
energy that's what i'm doing i did well
in my business and i'm working on ubi
works because this is what the world
needs and it brings me a lot of joy to
work on these things
um so he said it that we would have
solved this so you know i asked the
listeners if this was possible
wouldn't this be our responsibility to
pursue this if this is really possible
we should we should fight for this this
is far more than than a
guaranteed basic income and by the way
this is the first time in public i'm
never speaking about these things i've
been very shy about it but but andrea i
want to honor you because you've been
such an inspiration to me so i wanted to
say these things in public and use this
as the launch pad and uh and tell you
how we might get to keynes's vision
because it's basic income is the
beginning and i think i think
commonwealth
is is going to be part of the journey to
get there overall
so the economic problem has been solved
a number of
nobel prize winning economists have said
his predictions for growth have happened
actually we even understated by an order
of magnitude so the amount of
productivity growth kane said we would
need to solve the problem has been
happened happening but these naysayers
like but but then everyone else looked
at it and said well
obviously it hasn't he was wrong because
look we're still working alongside
i mean we clearly have the wealth to be
able to do what he said i mean if you
just run the numbers uh
we can
provide for every person certainly
uh in the developed world easily and the
developing world if you
uh you know adopt
like the appropriate um
cost uh changes in other parts of the
world like we could provide for everyone
on the planet
we absolutely could and even the word
provide though is kind of suggesting
it's charity and and that's actually
where i think uh
commonwealth resolves that because it's
not charity it's it's co-ownership of
something that makes us money and that's
much simpler and it's more pride in that
so so the the economic problem
it's in reach it's the productivity is
there
and so i think what keynes was hinting
at in his essay because economists are
very careful like anyone's listened to a
central bank try and forecast interest
rates knows they're going to be very
careful of what they say they might hint
at things that they want but they'll
never say it clearly because they could
get in trouble they could lose their job
they could be mocked in their career
this is it's always been this way where
economists speak and riddles so i think
much of his essay is actually describing
not the economic problem that would be
resolved but the political problem that
would need to be resolved this is
fundamentally a political problem not an
economic one and he left a lot of clues
in his essay to suggest what the actual
solution is
um he mentioned that we would be able to
discard not that we would we'd be able
to discard
all kinds of social customs and economic
practices affecting the distribution of
wealth and the economic rewards and
penalties the incentives that the system
operates in
that we previously justified because
they grow the economy
but if we already reach this level of
abundance when economic growth is not
being
paraded as like the sole thing that will
make your life better because it will
make you jobs and make you higher pay
which it's not it's been disconnected
from wage growth for a long time then
something's got to give politically so i
think he was inviting us to create a
movement
and he literally said the word nervous
breakdown that he implied that
individually or societally it would be
like a nervous breakdown we'd have to go
through to let go of these customs and
ideas that are holding us back
a nervous breakdown here's an example if
i tell you you should pay for someone
else not to work
you might have a nervous breakdown but
or that people don't need to work
anymore that we can't even conceive of
this but but no one is actually saying
that someone should pay for someone else
not to work that's actually not not the
case at all
you know he just but but even conceiving
of a society where not everyone has to
work
it even makes me nervous thinking about
it she's like what are people gonna do
like what's gonna happen like it's there
is a nervous breakdown we have to go
through and i believe that keynes also
implied that technological unemployment
might be the trigger for it he actually
opened up the essay mentioning
technological unemployment early on and
then doesn't mention it again uh just
mentions these other things that i had
said and he defines it as labor-saving
technology
that's adopted faster than we can find
new uses for labor
and that we will struggle with how to
use this freedom from economic need that
technology
and compound interest so grow economic
growth has brought us but as you know
well know it happened to my family in
the 2000s those manufacturing workers
the technology frees us from time but it
also frees us from income so what's the
solution it was in kansas essay
he said
those who have an independence an
independent income but no associations
duties or ties to
and none of the commentators who have
evaluated the essay picked up on that
point because he kind of hid it in a
description of of what wealthy people
have and he said wealthy people are the
first people to get there he didn't say
like we can be like them he said no the
first people to get to the promised land
are the wealthy of his time and they
have independent income with no
associations or duties or ties and he's
he the essay lays the case that all of
us will have that soon
so to me this again comes to wealth
co-owning some form of wealth
and as you know wealthy people they
don't make money from income they make
money from assets assets make money for
them um so i think that was the hint he
was giving us is that an independent
income it's basically like a basic
income but but not only the basic income
some form of of co-owned wealth that
pays us a dividend is how we get to star
trek the next generation
[Applause]
[Music]
i love the vision um i struggled with
what that looks like uh yeah yeah you
know i mean i and i i do think there are
steps to be taken
um
basic income to me strikes me as like a
an enormous step in this direction
and
right now particularly in this era where
uh you're seeing some flexibility let's
say in terms of
um
what governments can do uh in so far as
um
if you have a global reserve currency
you know you still can uh make big moves
um so
i think that the us is in a very
powerful position to be able to do this
um
and
i'm curious
what your
examination of keynes's essay
leads you to think are the steps that
you want to work on in canada with ubi
works
if you look at cain's
other parts of keynes's life things that
he had said that would be you know
probably obviously he had this vision he
was against something called um rentier
capitalism he he said at the very end of
his theory of general um everything
whatever that we need to take the
rentier aspect out of capitalism a
capitalism isn't the problem its
economic rents uh are the problem and
economic rents is a form of profit uh
that joseph stiglitz the another nobel
prize winning economist says is is
profit we make without working for it
without adding any value in return
there's a growing consciousness around
rentier capitalism which guy standing
the foremost world expert on basic
income talks a lot about
um and and and keynes in his and
at the end of his general theory he
talked about the euthanasia of the
rentier he called it the functionless
investor the investor makes money and
doesn't work for it and that's a lot of
commentators um a lot of experts are
saying that it's actually this aspect of
of capitalism where we're extracting
rents that mainly go to the the top one
percent or uh that is actually slowing
down uh prosperity for everyone and is
is extractive as opposed to inclusive
so um so
the the plan is and this is the
beginning his first time ever saying
this in public is to try and create a
movement around citizen rent seeking
let's create common wealth that captures
these rents uh into a commonwealth
sovereign wealth fund of sorts that can
invest this money in stocks and bonds
and create wealth that everyone owns
that can get a dividend from
and and that's where i think that
a basic income
won't get us to kane's vision because
it's seen as an anti-poverty program
through the lens of efficiency minimal
tax increase usual left versus right
dichotomy
but you know but but commonwealth will
get us there much like it did in in
alaska so in alaska the the excess
profit from oil extraction is by
definition economic rent
in norway they take out even more norway
collects 80 of the of the profits from
rent extraction and puts it into their
sovereign wealth fund and if they chose
to to pay people a dividend from that
fund everyone in norway could get 10 000
a year right now uh which is incredible
but they're using it to pay for public
services instead which i'd argue is a
form of tax break for the wealthy
because if they if they funded those
public services through normal income
taxes the wealthier would be paying more
if they did what alaska did instead and
gave everyone a dividend people would be
more equal
more bottom-up prosperity and as we know
alaska has the the most equal
state in the u.s
um
so you know what what what people do
with their their income from their
wealth or the oil dividend is no one
else's business no one goes into saying
hey we're giving dividends to lazy
people because we own the oil together
yeah this is an argument i was making
with data as the new oil uh and what i
referenced before energy like oil was
the main
energy form that people talk about
divvying up
uh
there's also a movement around
decentralized organizations where if you
can imagine an uber
where every uber driver is an uber owner
like in a node as opposed to having the
these
uh shareholders above them
uh and so there are a lot of folks who
uh believe that this is the direction we
have to go certainly our current system
is not very
geared toward this uh and
the the struggle is that
um
the folks that would benefit most from
this
are right now excluded from uh being
able to create some of these kinds of
organizations and that that is changing
as you can tell like i'm not
hesitant where i i still think that
this has to happen politically
uh and then if it happens politically
then all things become possible
um but i'm all for
uh entrepreneurial independent
approaches towards cooperative
wealth building leadership
yeah absolutely i mean i i
i have a lot of debates with people in
the crypto space i own some crypto and
uh they keep saying this is the bl
end-all solution to everything and i
keep telling them like you know what the
financial sector is just one monopoly of
many like yes we we need it it'll take
the rents out of the system like if
effectively if you're using financial
services
on on various blockchains
there's much less rent being collected
rent by definition is the excess profit
above and beyond what's needed to
produce those services that you're using
so you can have an account with less
fees you can transfer things with less
intermediaries it takes the middleman
out
so so any decentralized
endeavor or or private sector endeavor
that removes
uh more of this rent out of the system
means that they're providing services
better services for lower cost because
in a in perfect in an environment a
perfect competition there'd be no rent
because the competitors would bring
prices down so low that the profits
would just be what are required to
provide you this good in service and
that's where capitalism wins capitalism
wins as a way to incentivize
you know gazillions and gazillions of
independent people to provide solutions
to your problem for the lowest possible
price but capitalism fails when when
economic rents start being extracted
because of monopoly power that's given
by various authorities or companies get
so big that they can just start
extracting raising prices and extracting
more more more rent so so these various
examples of rent you mentioned well
certainly certainly the rent seeking in
america is sky high
where people talk about as if they're
they're fair markets competition and in
most of these markets there really uh
has been
uh monopoly or near monopoly implemented
like anyone who thinks that amazon
versus the neighborhood retailer is like
genuine competition
it's like hey
worth a trillion dollars don't even need
to make money in any given period
that you have like the local store being
like oh you know i mean you know it's so
there's a lot of
um
a lot of rent seeking a lot of excesses
in the american system
and uh people
are still operating as if it was
you know 1940s or 50s where the the
market is functioning closer to what
they imagine it it's very dispiriting
how behind reality
most people are
uh the way they think about this so two
things one rent seeking yes
and renting is everywhere in the us and
if you were to get rid of it then uh
things would be very different and
better um but like most of the ways that
a lot of the wealthy individuals and
institutions are making money are
essentially rent seeking at this point
like if you're like like that's the
entire franchise um so so if you were to
get rid of it it would be
extraordinarily disruptive um not that
i'm not saying that's necessarily the
worst thing in the world but i'm just
pointing out that that's the case um the
second thing is that when you talk to
your friends in the cryptocurrency space
i have friends maybe not you know the
the same friends or as many friends but
yeah they're all like look like stop
messing around with this other stuff
like you know uh just
like digital currencies bing bang the
end
lot like like your mouth we just like
skip right to it um and i love that
uh attitude and energy
um and i would love to see it happen and
and the blockchain is what will enable
some of these decentralized
organizations uh that i was referring to
before so i i'm excited about the
possibilities
yeah absolutely i mean i actually had to
unfriend
someone who was just badgering me after
i did a facebook post about rent seeking
he's like dude it's all about crypto
fiat blah blah blah take down the
government i'm like dude do you
understand that finance is not the only
monopoly right like we can take out that
monopoly great maybe he's slightly
better off but it's not going to change
the incentive to extract rent out of out
of at the cost of environmental
destruction or the cost of labor
exploitation there's tons of and seeking
that can still hurt beyond money
creation
and there's a bigger picture here you
know rent is much more than just just
like the banking system oh
i
love where you've gone floyd um you're a
beautiful human being and a brilliant
thinker
uh so if someone wants to help you
further your
vision in canada ubi works now taking
donations people can follow you on
various social media but what would you
ask people to do how did they stay
involved and help you
well right now i mean
i i'm kind of seeing two pass forward
one is we're gonna do everything we can
to promote a guaranteed minimum income
now because it is the quickest way to
relieve a lot of suffering and to
improve our economy and also up
emancipate millions of people to think
more long-term and if they can think
more long-term things like
like taking on the rents
creating a ubi from co-ownership
sovereign wealth funds that can actually
solve the bigger issues that create
inequality in the first place will
actually have a chance so i i kind of
see us running two different tracks one
is the the base income track and there's
a commonwealth track which will be about
educating and creating awareness of
rents and also the some of the the
harmful aspects of rents so you know for
example like climate change um and the
crazy property market we have in canada
right now where like
housing prices are going insane
and part of that is because of land
rents and and sort of perverse
incentives that are baked into the
system that i think um uh ubi as a as a
funding uh as a place where the money
goes if we pay its land tax for instance
could be a compromise that people would
accept as opposed to just more money
going to the government if that means a
more stable housing market so i i'm
trying to think of like each of these
categories of rent what can we do to
create movements around them that could
be all be funneled and this is one idea
of like give everyone a ubi so we all
get a share of the rents and we can all
benefit together and and create a
sustainable future but the thing you can
do right now is just sign up on ubi
works follow us on all the channels uh
engage in all the activism we ask you to
and uh and yeah you can donate or
whatever but uh
we're i'm gonna be at this for a while
you know when i started ubi works i had
an intention to do it for four years
and just two years left in that mandate
and uh and including my the funding of
it uh so we hope to get more more
fundraisers just in case we don't uh
close the basic income in the next two
years and then i want to probably focus
on commonwealth maybe for the next 10
years because i think that is how the
bigger picture how we get to keynes's
vision for a better world
it's a race people canada versus the
united states floyd versus me
who's gonna win i'd take either of us
getting there because if one of us gets
there then the you know if canada gets
there and the u.s will look up and be
like what
and certainly if the us gets there then
canada would be like i cannot believe
the us beat us to it so let's
freaking push both countries forward as
quickly as possible and the rest of the
world floyd thank you so much my friend
thank you so great to spend this time
with you and rooting for you supporting
you every step of the way
thanks so much
[Music]
you